yeah we're good chin we're ready here
it's just the og crew just the other
meatball with me baldo
there it is i feel honored there it is
yep keeping it all we got a meatball
sandwich here i gotta compliment you on
these chairs
very comfortable very comfy i mean my
back
everything is good he likes daddy likes
and daddy
daddy's proud of himself maybe my
biggest accomplishment in my 50
at 54 is that i've gotten myself
physically
to a place where i can drive from san
diego for three hours
and then sit here for two and my back
doesn't hurt and when i get up out of
the chair
my back isn't tight i think that's
impressive because you're a small man
well i'll be honest you're smaller
because i'm consistent with
how i'm working out with my my booty so
i'm doing all this stuff that lauren
landowner baby
smaller guy bubba i'm telling you you
know no i would i would agree with you
do your friends that have the well the
problem is my 20s my 30s and my 40s my
back was disaster oh
you had backpacks oh yeah dude all the
time all that all the time
and then i started doing all these
different exercises to help it out like
bulgarian
and there's nothing worse than back bro
a neck might be well neck
neck when you're like this how about
that when that is there anymore
this morning i drove from how was the
traffic was it bad traffic no but
there's always something
what's always when it breaks down here
orange county gets dicey yeah and then
there's like [ __ ]
but it wasn't terrible no no no it's a
nice drive if it's not bad
it's a nice drive not a bad drive at all
i like the drive coming here
because i love the pca oh man that's
malibu and peaceful
hard to have a bad day yeah i got no
problem i leave
with an hour to spare and i and i just
glide up and i listen to books on yeah i
miss those
a little bit i mean we do it five times
a week it's a little bit much but
at least you know two three times a week
freeze not bad yeah not bad at all
i like it i like it i can't believe we
only did one night in san diego i love
[ __ ] san diego so i like to chill man
it's like i was having this conversation
with justin uh at ca
he's a guy well let's do wilbur one
night i'm like bro girl
i'm not flying to boston for one night
dude
i want to feel the city i had a friend i
go i'd rather do boston comedy club
he's like i know but just looks wise you
know you've been doing theaters and
to go back to club i'm like dude for who
what do you mean look for other comics i
don't give a [ __ ]
i'd rather make my nut at the boston
comedy whatever it is yes
yes and do five shows or six shows
correct then one night in wilbert and
then get on the plane the next day and
fly [ __ ] five hours can't do that
no when you're like when you're in the
musical act you do that oh yeah
and and you do that for one year yeah
you live on patreon
you know so yeah yeah singing the same
thing but i like to [ __ ] feel the
vibe of the city i would get my beak wet
dad yes you're big his weak is dry
your beak gets dry it gets dry can't get
your beak wet with just one
night oh right got to dip your toe
got to get my toes and my beak wet get
this beak
that's all [ __ ] deep dog right in the
box
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what's a
good name for an [ __ ]
honey hole if it's clean mud whistles
dirty super gay
that's a little gay huh yeah honey let
me go ahead and get a gander your
your uh your honey hole yeah they ever
tell you the story that that peter
farrelly
the you know fairly brothers peter
farley petty farley um
funny uh some something about mary and
all these guys who are amazing
yeah all those movies so he and his
brother couple jokesters
and and and dad is a doctor and mom is i
think a housewife but they're they're an
irish family and silly geese they're
just silly geese
and i've had some interaction with peter
fairley who's an outstanding guy
and always a silly goose and always a
great guy yeah on the right yeah you
guys looks like a giant bird
so i'm gonna i think it was i think it
was him who did this or it was brother
who did this
so his brother they've been out at night
and and dad's watching sunday
morning football and so peter comes in
uh and he's he's kind of like he's he's
kind of uh he's like ah
he kind of like limps in and he and he
goes and he sits down he goes
like what the [ __ ] his dad's a doctor so
that goes the hell is wrong with you and
he goes
i don't know my [ __ ] asshole's
killing me
and his father goes what because my
[ __ ]
my asshole's just it's really hurting me
and his father goes the
[ __ ] are you talking about your [ __ ]
what are you talking about and he goes
i don't know it's just i woke up and
it's absolutely killing me i can barely
sit down
his father's doctor and he goes let me
see your [ __ ] then show me here
somebody
pull your pants down let me see because
i don't want to do that he goes let me
see it if you're got a problem it could
be dave
let me see what's going on don't don't
you know walk in here like
and he goes you want me to show you my
he goes i do i mean just let me see it
nobody's here just let me see it
so peter fairley pulls his pants down
and in his hands no
there's a condom sticking out of his ass
and his father goes
oh god damn it jesus christ he goes what
the [ __ ]
show your mother show him her and he
calls his mother and
that's the kind of family they have
that's hilarious i know he just [ __ ]
with this
have you have you ever had hemorrhoids i
have had
like the ones that won but very you
would know yeah i had a grape hanging on
my ass
oh well that that's from squatting i
just think from life
and i remember at the show club from
what i was telling club and
it's weird because i'll never forget
this i was driving down the road and i
was like oh my god my [ __ ] is
itching like never before yeah so you
start itching
and then it's like god it's burning and
then you're like what do i drop a grape
between my ass cheeks
it's like no bubba that's the vein
popping out of your [ __ ] that's a
real hammer
it's so bad to take a [ __ ] it's insane
now do you push it back in your sh
no i did i just put it and it went away
yeah i never was uh
the clown was like nothing to say i told
clown like dude you got to see this
thing and he's like yeah i got it i'm
like
it's insane you can feel it it's not
that bad but then i i did i like spread
eagle into the mirror i'm like oh my god
yeah i have a [ __ ] grape gusher
hanging on my ass
so then i showed klopp and he was like
oh oh my god i'm like dude it's bad
it's [ __ ] bad he's like what are you
doing you go to the doctor
so then you google it and they like what
they can do is they'll tie it off with
rubber bands so it dies yeah can't
become is that what they do
or yeah they tie it off and then they
they like singed it they
tie it off they had tied off so i saw
that like i just i just pushed it back
she needed that poopy face i think the
scene you get that little poopy finger
yeah yeah that brown figure for a month
never tell you here i say that i just
pushed it back in there never
never came back i had a feature i had a
feature i didn't do soft
yeah yeah that's sometimes you did i had
a feature who i didn't know very well
and i never forgot this he's a nice guy
young guy and i'd met him doing a thing
and he said can i open for you we were
in uh
where the [ __ ] were we uh doesn't matter
oh florida so we're in florida and um
and i go to pick him up because he
doesn't have a car we're gonna go to
breakfast
and he's he's a real chipper guy
and he's sitting on the stoop and his
head
is in his hands and i thought i was like
yeah
that's somebody died yeah murdered
something somebody died yeah something's
up oh dude
and so i go hey he looks up at me hey
hey and he looks like he's seen a ghost
i go hemorrhoids dude what's going on
man
gets in i go you all right he goes uh
yeah i'm just gonna
he's doing you know i can tell he's very
nervous and i go what's wrong with you
what's wrong with you and he goes i mean
this is really hard to talk about and
i go well talk to me i'm older it
doesn't matter you know what the [ __ ]
happened you know unless you killed
somebody don't worry about it
and he goes i gotta i got something
going on down here
yeah and i go something going on he goes
let me see papa i go let me see uh let
me see your call's not sucking
he pulls his dick out oh is that it was
on his dick in hemorrhoids and
he and i and i look at it and he goes i
i think it's just probably a pimple i go
oh it hurts that's you had to hurt but
oh you got the hurt
oh no and he had slept with a girl and
then he had started dating another girl
that he's
in he was loved well so he gave it to
her so he was in love with but he had to
tell her but he was so afraid she was
going to break up with him because he
loved her
like he wanted to settle down with this
girl and so it was such thing and i go
dude
you got to tell her you got to tell her
just call her up and tell her and let
the chips fall where they may and just
throw yourself at the mercy she was
still down she had it too
she goes i i've had it oh she had
previously yeah i've had a couple horses
yeah yeah so a couple of scumbags yeah
damn what a man that night he was like
hey
i thought you can see you can't wait to
do stand up i thought you were gonna say
you had uh hemorrhoids
no it's scary when a vane spider if he
had hemorrhoids i wouldn't have looked
at his [ __ ]
i don't know what you guys do there's no
way i even with you
a good friend if you're like can you
look at my [ __ ] i'd go i'm not going
to look at it because i'll be
traumatized china your age you've never
had hemorrhoids
i'll never tell hemorrhoids yeah i've
had an itchy [ __ ] before i
don't know nothing like a purple thing
that pops out of my ass let me take a
little you know let me see what's going
on
no no yeah i've had an itchy [ __ ] of
course everyone does
yeah i think the hemorrhoids look if you
if you've ever seen like
you know a tree you know like the the
hole in the tree
yeah that looks like an [ __ ] think of
that and then think of a giant purple
worm coming out of that hole
that's a problem huh that's hemorrhoids
well you could if you don't google
hemorrhoids because you'll
you'll see some textbook [ __ ] that'll
throw a lot of you know a lot of
pregnant women get because they're
pushing so hard trying to get that baby
out
the [ __ ] goes we're gonna break free
now yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of
things that happen
so i do do you remember that video will
sasso sent
us a long time ago that that guy
fisting another guy's [ __ ] and then
he would take the [ __ ]
sock it out yes i do it was the most
disturbing video i've ever seen in my
life he sends me
he'll send me now just pictures of bears
dancing
and i'm like oh look it's a bear and
then it's a bear and then it's a bear
like ripping off the head of an elk you
know just as a threat to me yeah but
yeah he sends me all kinds of stuff like
that but
i don't like those videos i don't either
i don't i don't like that
i don't like when you oh you mean you
wait you don't like when somebody pulls
someone's anus out of their body you
don't like that
it was very foreign
that's not my thing he has two like
little twinks he's just like elbow deep
in their asses
i don't like that well my mother you say
anything you can think of has been done
to another human being true
fact yeah and that's that's where the
internet shows you the depravity
and that's when you realize by the way
how normal you are
yeah i mean i mean kind of but we are in
their own way
not really though like like let's be
honest
i know you you know me we're not into
weird [ __ ]
like i'm just not no i'm into yeah i'm
just not i know i like the regular stuff
you know the regular stuff is is plenty
yeah for me
i don't need to be i don't need you
kicking me in the nuts while i while i
suck a banana or whatever the [ __ ]
people are into or being dressed in
diapers yeah
yeah i don't need to march me around the
house on a leash and like spank
don't need that either no that's not
going to get me off nope it needs to
make no sad my knees will hurt for sure
yeah yeah i don't need any of that stuff
i don't need that stuff it's a weird
thing
meat and potatoes dude meat and potatoes
i'm a meat and potato guy
meat and potato guy we wore the same
shirt today yeah i'm i'm simplifying
things
in my life not drinking and wearing i
had wine last night you know what uh
what better show i'm into if they're
drinking something i drink it
i think i'm just like oh that'd be nice
yeah like like with yellowstone
i drank whiskey the entire season all
three seasons i get it because game of
thrones
wine like uh tyrion the little the
little man
he's my favorite character
one episode left and i always see him
drinking wine so
it makes you a little thirsty yeah my
girl was like you know you're drinking
wine every night i'm like yeah it's game
of thrones [ __ ]
yeah yeah i've see i've i know that
feeling because you'll see a guy
roll a cigarette and i don't like
cigarettes but the way that tobacco
talk about it you'll be like i can see
how that would be enjoyable yeah i'll
[ __ ] smoke
you know what i mean yeah like i'll
smoke right now yeah like a
filterless i thought about going
old-school fire because i was gonna
[ __ ] have some whiskey man
yeah yeah there's whiskey outside yeah
yeah
grab grab that it's almost friday not
that tiger thick
it's almost friday can you grab extra
glasses too you haven't tried the tiger
thing
no no it came out mass producing what's
coming out
uh it'll be ready by uh mid-september
wow you don't realize how much of a
beast it is to come out with your own
whiskey to come out with your own
whiskey not bad huh it's
the way you talk about the way you
market it it's just i mean you can't go
direct to customer it's got a consumer
it's got to go through
yeah all that stuff and you want to see
because we're going to do a thing where
every club i go to they have to buy a
certain amount of bottles
they're dealing with certain city laws
state laws
club laws they use this dis distribution
chain they don't use yours yeah that's a
lot of it it's a whole mafia
oh but and then you want to do japanese
whiskey well has to be ten years age and
a barrel
of whiskey in japan oh certain barrel
and but then that can only be a certain
amount of japanese whiskey
to mix with american bourbon and then
they have to okay all those bottles
you don't say oh no grab it not the red
bottle grab the other one
yeah one's like that one's a prop it's
probably not alcohol
i pissed in that one are you serious i
don't want to drink it more
no i'm just kidding ah see i knew see i
know he's gonna do this oh whiskey
yeah you want to drink my pee pee have
you guys i mean have you shown the world
yet no no no
haven't supposed to be the first time
the actual bottle yeah no i don't think
the world's ever
seen wow i ain't seen it i'll give it my
seal of approval it is
legit dope yeah yeah so it's 10 years
old
the the japanese whiskey is 10 years old
aged 10. so you got a flame over it came
over on
ships from japan so you got a game of
thrones you got to find a
you got to find a distillery that has
whiskey which my partners did they they
deal with
all that yeah and then i go through all
the taste and all that
i was gonna save for the fight companion
of saturday but who to do it better with
than you
no this one's fine come on we got this i
mean i'd rather do with callum than
anybody come on i also wish we had ice
but
a rat spell yeah we need some ice we
need to have ice in the freezer it's all
right sometimes you want to drink it
straight
drink straight like it's a thursday i
mean i take my son to just after this
but yeah
i like the way it smells i already like
it check out that label big daddy i like
that label too
they're nice i like that a lot you know
it's a tall bottle like this
why because when you're at a restaurant
if it's short bottles they get lower
[Music]
did you lick this with your mouth
christian do you want do you want some
oh yeah i'm definitely gonna have some
this one
the best part away where everybody was
catching up thick tiger
in your cup go ahead and wash that
because i don't like
alcohol kill all of it no i know that
but i just say
when you're breaking the whiskey let's
get a clean glass all right you got to
be a little bit more
you know yeah but i've been drinking
wine during game of thrones man i have a
big old now do you
do you big glad and then i you know how
that one like viking guy drinks it the
wildling yeah with the red bear and he
just gives it all over i don't
do that you do does it affect you the
next morning never because i only have
one glass yeah but
then i hit the ground a running at six
am yeah i'm with tiger then i go to the
gym so i shake all of it out before i
see you
yeah am i supposed to if i drink more
than two glasses we got
his eyes swell shut up yeah about it
daddy gets all kinds of swollen yeah and
thick daddy over here i need to chill
out on the sodium so i don't have this
fat face that's what it is
sodium sodium fat face what kind of my
friend mark says
what kind of food you eating i mean
sodium it's filled name of
food with sodium you just like your salt
cheerfully what yeah you said it yeah
yeah
the hands get all this little hands get
a little no no nothing my feet do on the
road yeah papa's feet swell on the ropes
i'm on my feet feet and face well my
girl my girl has that issue my girl eat
she loves sodium and she loves her carbs
so she'll wake up sometimes and i'm like
well i don't know who you are she has
pan face she's she'll get she's pant
face yeah
pan face mcgee yeah it gets a little it
gets full that happens
she you know i do now what i like to do
is uh
i'll have my dinner and i take this
multivitamin i forget the name of it
it's six
thick vitamins i mean i really gotta
deep soap these vitamins to get them
down
but they have digestive enzymes in them
yeah that next morning dude
you feel good dude take a nice poo oh my
god it has bombs over baghdad yeah
yeah yeah what's it what is it so you
take your digestive enzymes
at night at night to break down all the
food i ate like if it's like red meat or
something like what time do you take it
i have to take it before six otherwise
it keeps me up now what time do you
eat i eat it i put tiger at down at
seven so i usually eat around 7 15.
that's discipline because if you if i
eat at nine i'm but you know
on the road like i either just don't eat
like i'll eat before
like four and then i went the next day
to like one on the road that's good
i mean i guess good i guess keeps you
thin i get i mean
relatively thin well we had uh
you met the the young man on monday who
came and worked out with us
i did how was he it'd been good for you
to be there because and
he struck because he did play college
football so he had he so he deadlift
like 315 but you know
he marked it doing i see the video 575
you did and i showed it to the guy i was
getting my hair cut
and i said he didn't know me and he was
kind of a
sensitive man and not a weightlifter
i said now now i want you to watch my
friend lift
this weight and then i want you to
understand he's a black belt in jiu
jitsu so he can
he can he can strangle you
and he kind of went and i go and he's
got a medium dick too and i said and he
goes let's say medium large
i'm giving you medium large it's just
that your body's big
yeah but still medium large yeah dude
seven seven seven inches
all right which is where they're gonna
come from seven seven five all right all
right be cool
everybody be cool yeah now i need a
little now your nuts are bigger than
mine i'll give you that well i got a
little
i i got you be in general i don't think
so
i would say they're pretty similar your
nuts are bigger hey now
i'm gonna pull the trump card here no
pun intended yeah pull the trump
trump has a tiny dick we know this but
jay schabb
no no jay's got me you know who has the
biggest in the room christian
i saw yesterday you saw him no yesterday
i saw that he i
i looked at the outline of his pants
because that you know i take him
in it's usually fine i haven't had a
chance to take a man in but i took him
in and i went
kid's got kids working with some there's
some meat going on i told you his
brother
who i'm close with johnny goes listen i
don't give my brother a [ __ ] inch but
the kid has a dick on him all right
congratulations now you're wearing the
yeezy sketchers is that what's going on
there no these are apls i i couldn't
afford the easy sketchers yeah okay
out of my budget those are a little
elfish but that's yes those are very
those are very wildling i mean i only
wore them because they were free
so yeah well there might be a reason
they were freezing their apl's though
those are cheap
yeah that's why that's also why because
they're what's that shooty where seven
and a half
i got tiny feet bro you know his tiny
feet is kyle
he left it because he he couldn't pack
his shoes because he bought some new
ones i was like do i put him in my bag
yeah i was like okay it's like an
ornament you hang on a [ __ ] tree
yeah i said what i put in my bag and my
girl
my girl goes it's like an ornament you
hang on a tree
my girl goes who's [ __ ] because they
look like chick shoes she goes who's
[ __ ] cause of the green pine jordans
yeah whose [ __ ] shoes are those i'm
like kyle's she's like
your videographer has that small [ __ ]
foot like
when a woman says that i'm like yeah
she's like so he must be [ __ ] tiny
i'm like
yeah he's tiny she's like he wears a
seven and a half i'm like
yeah [ __ ] because she wears a
seven-half yeah she's like i can wear
those i'm like
i mean i guess i can offer money if you
want to work those are his [ __ ] shoes
lady
those are some chicks there's a book
there's a book called pugilist the
pugilist at rest it's a series of short
stories one of the best
things i've ever read cheers buddy and
cheers to your whiskey and cheers
as well cheers to light at the end of
every tunnel yeah uh
i read this and and she's that's [ __ ]
good it's smooth right bubba that's good
that's smooth
that's a nice whiskey i would i'm not i
would tell you you'd like it that's a
nice whiskey
and take a second sip now i'm going to
tell you a story hold on
tiger thick do i get ten percent what do
i daddy's beaks dry
my beak is so dry i gotta get it a
little wet i mean i feel like it was a
bit of an inspiration
i agree right now beautiful
now um let's take a little break from
the shenanigans with the old man
aka the kid because with today's low
interest rates it's a great time to
refinance your student loans
say goodbye to stressful student loan
payments and take charge of your future
with earnest
earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing
you can check out your rate risk free in
just two frickin minutes
with earnest you get flexible payments
you can pick your loan term it's all up
to you man
by refinancing you can reduce your loan
terms save money
combine multiple loans into one simple
monthly payment
if you have any questions you can talk
to real human being at earnest for help
isn't it time you stop feeling
overwhelmed by student debt
all right ernest is offering you guys
cash bonus refinance your student debt
at earnest.com
fighter terms conditions apply now
it is earnest all right ernest you get
100 cash
dollar bonus when you visit earnest.com
fighter to refinance student loan it's
not available in all states term
conditions apply
it's my favorite part visit earnest.com
for more details terms conditions apply
earnest student loan refinancing made by
earnest
operations l-o-c-n-m-l-s number one two
zero four nine one seven california
finance and law license number
six zero five four seven eight eight
three 303 second street suite 401
north san francisco california 94107
and if you're still listening visit
earnest.com licenses for a full list of
licenses
again that's earnest.com
fighter all right kids you look you i
told brian his hair was leaving i went
dude you need to do something about it
you want to keep the hair that you have
dude and
listen you're not you're not alone in
this bald world
that bar god's not only your barber i
see multiple dudes that are losing their
hair
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time
they're 35
all right and here are my friends at
keeps they offer a simple stress free
way to keep your freaking hair
don't be like brian kellen keep what you
got it's low cost treatments are just
ten dollars per month keeps
offers generic versions shows up
discrete little package
proven results man no no snake or hill
talk about real
stuff here prevention is key treatments
can take four to six months see results
so act right now
before it's too late and you're going
bald if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com fighter to receive your first
month of treatment for free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fighter
to get your first month free
keeps.com fighter uh there's a
she she talks about this woman talks
about how she's she's in love with this
he's like a bank robber
pearl diver kind of a ruffian big strong
[ __ ] huge hands and and and just she
can't get enough of them sexually and
she's
but she's married to a dude who's got
lots of money and she's married him for
money
and she talks about how the book she
yeah she compares
she's watching her husband butter his
toast
and he's got little fingers and little
hands and she
she's watching him he's particular about
how he butters
his toast right and he's like and he's
he's got his hands are manicured
and he's butter and he's and in her mind
she's watching the price she's paid
to marry a dude and all she can think
about is this [ __ ]
ruffian this brute who she had a fight
with because he was [ __ ] the spanish
dancer and then he still had sex with
her and she was like she forgave him
because it was it felt so good
and she loves him yeah good day he's
like sorry sorry i love you and he's
like i don't want to know i fell into it
the whole thing and i never forgot the
way she just paid the ultimate price
it's like it's like harvey weinstein's
wife yes like i know
big powerful guy gorgeous so hot oh but
she has to sleep next
time and he's farting you know he's
farting and you know he puts on his toes
growth on his growth on his head he
married a troll [ __ ]
you're paying the price lives under a
bridge i bet when his [ __ ] was coming
out she's like oh thank god get rid of
this [ __ ] guy
they're horrifying meanwhile think about
he's bringing her to all the oscar
parties she's meeting
brad pitt all those jared leto now she's
dating
adrian brodie bet your [ __ ] ass shoes
he has a nose on him but whatever
yeah but dude that he's a goddamn 10
compared to harvey weinstein correct
correct yeah dude those people pay a
price
they say if you marry for money you pay
for it every [ __ ] day every day you
don't get away
with lying you don't get away with lying
to yourself well the guy knows
but that rich guy knows it too correct
rich guys i guess we'll have a kid and
we'll be roommates that's right you
gotta [ __ ] me every now and then that's
right that's no different than game of
thrones
they're just married for you know family
status yeah i mean [ __ ] that
you can't do nightmare people do that
yeah i would even say you can do that
with a job you can take a job and if
you're doing it just for the money
this is your life man this is your
[ __ ] life money buys good things but
if you're spending 9 10 15 hours a day
working at something you don't like yeah
you might have a high salary but you can
be
miserable i've seen it a thousand
thousand million times i told you like
dove
dove david off one time the greatest
truth teller of all time
and i i called dove probably once a week
just to get a check in
on on life he's just puts in everything
he's [ __ ]
there he is the greatest the california
kid
and there was a guy we met he's with
this beautiful woman
and i think he kind of recognized me a
little bit and he's a young
handsome dude but he's with this trophy
this gal is just sitting there and she's
all you know and
um she's just this this this beautiful
girl and
in about five minutes the guy tells us
that he's not only has his medical
degree
he has his mba okay and that he's a
competitive he's a
competitive tennis player he plays yeah
against pros pays him probably
he plays in a in a he's a level five
which means you play in like what's he
going to do
it's not you're not a pro it just means
you play sure you play
you play a lot like you play against
other guys that play yeah but no one's
making money exactly and also nobody's a
pro yeah
and so that was listening to the guy
like this and just it was interesting he
goes he goes
wow you're lost
you're looking at all the wrong places
how about what's actually going on
but also he had that guy eating out of
his hand he gave him a whole [ __ ] but
also to
tell someone your accolades in the first
five minutes like bro
ego much like you how is it where are
you dude
i've been around such wealthy people and
in the first five minutes they're
telling me about how their house
was featured in architecture dude i
don't give a [ __ ]
like it's all good man i asked the guy
what he did at dinner in
in utah and he goes um he said well i'm
i write best sellers i have uh four best
sellers and i was like
oof that's an ego thing and no you don't
you know you don't yeah you also don't
but the other thing is unless you're
named steven king but the other thing is
is uh
when i've stopped doing it when people
go how you doing man busy
busy oh are you are you busy my favorite
yeah
but everyone says that and this too i
used to get this busy and having a lot
of fun
a lot of fun busy and just living man
busy
and yeah okay cool
yeah what are you hiding dude okay yeah
what are you hiding
what's going on that you're this busy
yeah yeah
because i think you hear it so much that
it becomes part of your vocabulary so
how you doing good man busy all right
dude well
it's such a like [ __ ] term right
your body gives away like a lot of stuff
there's this there's this podcast
mitch rouse's brother scott rouse has a
podcast which i didn't realize was huge
it's a youtube show
they get like 1.2 3 million views and
it's called the behavior panel
and they look at they will watch like
when we're like parents who are making
who've actually killed their kid but
they're making a fake plea
and they the way they get down there
yeah they've been doing this they all do
it on like a high level for like the
military
fbi like scott does all law enforcement
doesn't even stand any ground though in
court what's
guys yeah they're white though you know
yeah but they're all experts yeah i mean
that's where the experts you know yeah
and and one guy's from canada one's guys
english but dude the way they break this
[ __ ] down is so unbelievable it's
it's it's [ __ ] astonishing and you
people give themselves away
they just robert durst do i don't need
to see four experts say he's guilty yeah
but they do other stuff where they just
show you how easy it is for detectives
to go
this guy's a [ __ ] liar that's sweet
like you they'll let you talk
and while you're talking they're
analyzing everything you're giving away
you're
giving you're giving away you're in the
if if you're lying they see it every
time they see it every time but they're
really really good it's really fun to
watch
really fun it's it's it's amazing did
you
and they did the megan and harry thing
it was [ __ ] huge that is interesting
yeah
really really good really good yeah i'd
watch that for sure oh yeah
i think you'd love it actually because
you don't have any ones i care about
though hunter biden
i think hunter biden gets a bad rap well
all of them man the way they break it
down uh
mendez brothers are definitely into have
you seen look at this the staircase body
like
r kelly is super interesting staircase
scott peterson i've definitely watched
that one yeah scott peterson watched
that one michael jackson all said on
that
oh richard ramirez yeah i mean do we
need experts saying
well some of this stuff is interesting
to see how you can break it how he does
it yeah
and and it can be like wise when people
are telling little lies and you don't
know why like the oscars
oh chris watch jesus christ that's heavy
but the mendez brothers interesting
because what's interesting about mendez
brothers is now with the young
uh like tick tick tock yeah
they've looked into the case because
we're all they they [ __ ] kill to move
on dude
yeah but that young audience started
looking more into it and they watched
the case again
and you realize like these kids were
super traumatized molested
abused and now you look at 2021
when you watch some of these young kids
case for the men of brothers to be out
you're like
they have a [ __ ] appointment well
because back then like
mental health yeah molestation like it
was it wasn't
obviously it was viewed poorly but now
it's like
legit [ __ ] [ __ ] man i guess where the
case
hinged i've i've read a little bit about
a lot of things about the money
no when they reloaded the shotgun
they reloaded to kill the mom yeah that
was because originally so they shot the
dad
shot the mom and the mom kept moving and
then he reloaded to kill the mom
that's pretty brutal yeah you could
definitely left the mom alive but
although she's going to snitch on you so
i
get why they did it if you were a
murderer but um the dad yeah
like dude he was a [ __ ] horrible
person
horrible person was he yeah but the mom
kind of like the reason they had
they had anger towards their mom because
the mom a lot knew what was happening
allowed it to happen so what did happen
what are they what are they saying
so they're saying that the dad like beat
them molested them
the son was supposed to go to ucla and
the sun was like finally man i'm getting
out of here i'm gonna go live in the
[ __ ] dorms dad's like no you're not
you're gonna stay here
he's like no i'm not man i'm going to do
this he's like no you're not so he's
like super controlling
and then the dad kept threatening to
kill him and i guess that morning when
the dad left for work he was like if you
do this i'm gonna [ __ ] kill you guys
and he's beat them to like an inch of
their life and so they're like we gotta
do
so this is them saying i don't know the
story yeah this is them saying their
defense was
if we don't kill him he's gonna kill us
it's what's happening tonight
yeah it's tough right again i don't know
again like like
like we always say though why would you
build i don't think they did
cold blood you'd have to be to kill your
mom dude the thing is if the fbi guys
and the detectives that do this as a job
they see they see and are privy to so
much more than we are
right agree my only thing is in the
court of law like
i think society views things differently
so when you see all the trauma that
those kids grew up with and that what
the dad did to them
and then now they have other witnesses
who it shows how mean the dad was and
how connected
i think you and i would be we wouldn't
be the best you don't want me on there
no
because we've quit a lot of people yeah
i'm that way because i
i see and i go i see the best in people
usually every single time
you know what my friend said about me
he's a wealthy guy and he's
in and take it easy well he no what i
mean by that is that he's been very
successful
because he can read people very well and
he shuts them off or
so he's he's a guy who has to decide
whether or not somebody's worth
investing in or not so he's really good
at
doing that right yeah and he picks up on
his stuff it is and i'm not and he said
and and i said i just
i just see the i i might be and you know
what he said you're bad i'm bad you're
terrible i'm terrible
and he you know what he said to me which
was kind of a backhand comment and he
goes he goes
you make people feel good about
themselves because you see the best in
them
and you owe it when they're around you
it's their best
great it's the best version i never
thought of that you're getting the best
version
yeah and so so he said in as long as
i've known you're getting the honeymoon
he's known me since i was 18. and he
said as long as i [ __ ] known you
you've always said that guy's a good guy
and everybody else says he's a piece of
[ __ ]
and then i get burned but 10 years later
preach because i'm just
youtube right right youtube there you go
co-sign i can't help myself i'm always
like i i just
i want people you're getting the best
version of this i believe that they can
only keep that version up for so long
everybody
you're like oh no you're a piece of [ __ ]
rogan used to tell me that everybody
tell me you're bringing crazy in your
life you're bringing batteries
these are back for the wounded duck to
fix every time yep and i do it every
time because i just believe
i'm like no i can say i think i'd rather
have that than you'd be just a complete
dick to everybody that's who i am
rogan's good at reading people too
that's why he wastes no time well rogan
ubc someone's like dude
i get this pitch for the sweet no stop
and you like i'm like oh my god please
be nice strong
but then rogan's like dude you gotta
think about he's been famous how much
longer than all of us and he's like
these guys can do this they do this and
take advantage of this it's a waste of
time
to be and feels really really good at it
too yeah
do you call things out like on the show
with like
whether people work for the show or
they're involved with and like this
what's gonna happen
i'm like dude you're so you're so
paranoid dude and then
sure enough a year later i'm like god
damn you were right dude i uh
i'm really bad at that and my biggest
liability is that i have to admit and
it's bummer i think about a lot
maybe i'll never change i've gotten
better because i've had to get better
and i'm not as naive anymore
yeah and i and i um unfortunately i
would say
i'd say the pandemic everything that
went down during the pandemic is maybe
more i was just talking had that meeting
came in had that mean business made and
we're talking about the pandemic
how it's changed like the way you
operate i'm like i'm definitely more
cutthroat
me too i have to say that i am too and i
don't like that version of myself
i'm not more cutthroat i'm just i'm not
as worried about
i'm not as open to i'm not as worried
about people's feelings anymore and i'm
not worried i'm just worried
about it and i'm not as open or i i'm
definitely giving i think everyone here
can vouch for that you're very i'm
definitely like it's gonna
i'm not just gonna give you the world
right away anymore you're a softy
because
you'll have a problem with somebody and
the funny thing is brandon is like i
don't know what to do about this
and i'll talk to him and he's like and
he's just mad and then i go
i and i said so i think what we're going
to do in this case and correct me from
wrong
is absolutely nothing you'll do nothing
i mean he goes
that's right brian i'm going to do
nothing but i am going to complain about
it and i'm like okay i'll talk to you
tomorrow
and that's what happens and it has to
get so bad for me to cut you off
at such a level where i'm just like and
even then you give people chances
but let me ask you this how's it going
pretty well pretty william how's how's
it
going in your life pretty [ __ ] well
yeah i'd say you're winning true so at
the end of the day
yeah you know it's a headache at the
time though yeah and and
and uh i think that part of your
strength
like all of us part of your biggest
strength is also your weakness
but if you're if the strength outweighs
the weakness it's fine
it's like it's like parkinson's like
dead broken just giving my stuff away
but you're not and and and at the end of
the day you keep moving yeah
you know you we used to always talk
about that even the online [ __ ] all
the stuff
is you just keep moving forward it's all
noise it's all known
you keep moving forward and keep getting
better and keep writing
you know uh stephen west who's got
philosophized this
great podcast he came to your show and i
love his podcast
in which in which city tacoma and he and
steven is it's called philosophize this
he's a he's a he grew up i hope i'm not
sp but steve
said hi so stephen who i really respect
young guy rogan listens to this podcast
all the time you want to learn
philosophy this [ __ ] breaks it
down he grew up you know he was a foster
kid he had no parents
and philosophy was what raised him so
i'm talking about a young man who's read
every philosopher beyond smart but he's
also but he called he texted me and he
said
he said i just want to tell you that i
watched brendan and he was
[ __ ] unbelievable and he said
he just said that to me i didn't say
that to you but i bet it was pretty cool
to hear that you could have texted me
that though
yeah yeah but it's pretty cool man you
know it's pretty cool and he knows the
difference
and he's seen you from day one yes right
and so he was like he
he killed me he's become this he's
becoming a great i love it
that's a big deal that's huge that dude
knows what he's talking about so
huge deal shout out to stephen weston
philosophize this check out that podcast
god what a beast though oh he's a
[ __ ] beast that guy reads
everything and then breaks it down on a
level that blows what you do with it
well
yeah knowledge is power right like with
my son we do we talk about
sports all the time i'm like dude if you
really want to be different than all
your friends
read dude he's like really he's like
yeah and he's like
you know he sees all the books i all the
books i have he's like papa why do you
read so much i'm like because that's
power dude it's power
your your education is power i'm not
talking about school you're a's and b's
i'm talking about reading that and
getting [ __ ] you're interested in
it's like anything else it reading will
open the world to you you'll understand
the difference between a good idea and a
bad idea
and it's up to you though 100 and you'll
hear people talk and you'll you won't
fall for tropes you won't fall for
you know what i mean like if you've read
philosophy and somebody comes along some
cult leader comes along with this idea
and you go you're just repackaging a
bunch of [ __ ]
that it's it's a little bit like it
would probably be something like i would
imagine
as a martial artist as a fighter there's
just certain things that work and
certain things that don't now why do you
know that because you educated yourself
and if somebody comes in and goes if i
said dude you got to see this guy he
could win the ufc title
he can jump in the air and spin yeah and
break
ten boards he he jumped and you go
that's very cool brian but
and i go no no you understand he in the
air yeah and
i wouldn't know and but people fall for
the jumping wheels
like my girl was making fun of me for i
mean rightfully so i guess
because before we had our first kid
tiger i bought all these parenting books
she's like you know you learn as you go
and like or
like these book the people that wrote
these books they've been through it so
i'd like to hear from their experience
and they're going to tell you all the
fuck-ups so we shouldn't do
that that's why i read them dude i read
that made fun of me did you read raising
lions yes
you gave me that book joe knew that i
bought it no i gave it to you yeah
it's a good book it's a great book that
dude that dude works with the hardest
cases and i
i implemented that [ __ ] book and it
was unbelievable
it's unbelievable man joe newman you
think you're doing a good job as a dad
and then you stop at baskin robbins on a
wednesday afternoon in 105 degree heat
and you get out of the car and tiger's
like oh yeah dad i want ice cream
because i always give him ice cream
if he does well and we go in there and
they go uh he likes uh
cookies and cream ice cream yeah and i
go you gotta uh cookies and cream and
guys ah man we just ran out and ty goes
[ __ ]
so ah
so yeah yeah
you can't talk like that he's like what
you doing like i know i do
and that's how that's how dad talks but
you can do it around me
and you're on your friends but you can't
do it in public and i go
cause now you're making me look bad he
was really yeah it looks bad dude
when they run out of ice cream you go
[ __ ] because that's why because they'll
hear me like
joanna like oh we're all you probably
get it from me because two nights ago
she goes
we're all out of diet coke and ah [ __ ]
that's what he did we're all out of
cookies i love him i love him he's doing
his dad
my son's allowed to swear he loves to
swear but only around me that's
right he gets in the car and he's like
what the [ __ ] are we doing and he's just
i'm fine with it
that's how cause that's how i grew up
yeah when you tell them you cannot cuss
no matter what it's unrealistic stop
a b it's like it helps them with their
look at him there
it helps him he's like you yeah he's
like
it helps them with this stuff man you
know helps them figure it out
i love him he's cute as [ __ ] he's
jujitsu tonight
he's amazing 5 30 am he wakes me up this
morning he's like yeah we have jiu jitsu
i'm like yup
he's like if i do well i get ice cream
like sure do because they do this thing
where they go back to back and their
little geese
yeah and then he goes go and they switch
and they they gotta push the other one
down
and he's such a nice kid he lets him
push him down and he laughs
i'm like dude there's a time for games
and this time you gotta [ __ ]
this is the one place you can unleash
you're the biggest kid in there
you can unleash and use your strength
and size
yeah i'm like yes dude and that's why
they put you with older kids
does he have he's got he has it he's got
daddy's genetics oh yeah
he's a beast so he's just stronger than
a lot of kids because he's got a neck on
him
his neck on him yeah he's yeah look at
it's a great picture and he loves it
loves it
loves to go now he's going twice a week
it was once a week
right that's twice a week amazing long
[ __ ] day for the i told you ran like
19 000 some [ __ ] like that because i put
that little tracker on him
well he'll get done from summer camp at
3 30 i pick him up
don't get out of four it's a nightmare
he's jutsu at five
so he'll go straight from summer camp
because they're from nine to three
thirty
we'll stop get a snack and then go
straight to jiu jitsu we get home at
seven by time we get my ice cream i get
my [ __ ] uh you get my
hot chicken sandwich yeah he's ice cream
because he does well
okay cause i was giving my kids problem
with me is i would give my son my
son likes that dark chocolate from
jenny's super dark caffeine caffeine i'd
give him that
he pulled that down 7 30. i dropped him
off at mom's
and she's like hey dude hey dude
your son is running around i got a real
talking to
so now i i gotta videotape it when tiger
comes in from school
boston's at the gate going like this
grinding his teeth he's just ready to go
he wants to fight
oh all he wants to do is is that right
all he wants to do is wrestle his
[ __ ] brother
is that right he lives for it oh my god
look at that [ __ ] hair he looks like
he's ready for the wwe
by the way take a look at the hands on
that kid he's got
mitts he's got mitts did you superimpose
uh tim kennedy's hands on his wrist look
at those mitts
we're thinking about putting him on keto
he's got some mitts
yeah as soon as tiger gets in he's
waiting at the gate is that right
and if i put a fight on he goes like
this
i feel like joanna's uh family's pretty
athletic and strong too though yeah her
brother played college baseball and then
joanna has muscular
genetics her mother you've seen her mom
athletes joanna's a good athlete
oh yeah i remember we played volleyball
me too i was like goddammit what the
[ __ ] you're getting it all back
and you've seen her mom her mom be a
bikini at the pool like goddammit
yeah that's the hottest one what are we
doing she looks exactly like her
daughter
of all time i mean tiny wasted blow out
booty yeah
and put together yeah put i mean
discipline put together i'll just stare
at the fight because it's not a
hair right now like yeah no doubt and uh
yeah
have you played speaking of volleyball
you ever played spike ball on the beach
what's that
bring that up that's do you just spike
in people's faces
it's a game that i'm addicted to there's
like a little net you circle around like
you're all around the net and you
hit the ball like you and i would be
across from each other brian and chin
would be across from each other i bounce
it to you
it gets heavy let me see show so
show an intense game yeah let's see yeah
yeah watch this [ __ ]
it's this [ __ ] olympic sport right we're
not getting kicked off no no no no
no no no have you watched any of the
olympics oh yeah i love
yeah here's the problem though we showed
just a bit of olympics
from last wednesday's show and they took
it down within three seconds seconds
oh really you show any uh nbc sports
well they can [ __ ] off
yeah dude they need all the help they
can [ __ ] get i mean yeah exactly
exactly
this is a this is a cool [ __ ] this
gets so competitive and crazy i can't
even tell you
oh my goodness look at this watch this
i'm out look at this
yeah i'm out those guys are [ __ ] good
dude
and they have jerseys it's like
volleyball you [ __ ] but that's not
volleyball that's a trampoline and
that's it
you don't know anything and it's a great
i love when people say this because the
minute we played it you'd be like no i'm
not saying it's not fun i'm saying it's
out from watching grown men play
it's so much fun dude especially no it
does look fun but i'm out look at that
these guys are good
holy [ __ ] these kids are good they have
headgear on
this is the number one in the top ten
that's the idea
it's some fun man it's some look so
there's two guys and then
now you got to hit it under the ground
see that you got to hit it on the ground
and it balances and then you got to come
back to your friend
it doesn't look fun i feel like on a
beach would be at night
and [ __ ] no but i feel but i feel you
got to move oh look at this
yeah but it's fine you just you're
you're not gonna be able to move that
much but it's
because you can hit it anywhere as long
as you balance it now that's that's a
point well
because you couldn't get it back it'd be
down to play yeah it's fine once you
start doing it you're like well i want
to play this all the time
that does sound fun yeah yeah it's a
good time anyway
set up a little very happy thing here
play here it's nice huh
very happy with this oh you don't play
in here put some mats down
we need more space we're supposed to do
that right i don't need more space
out there might work yes you do it out
there a ring too we can box do all that
stuff
it would hit the ceiling though it gets
it goes high the game gets crazy all
right take it easy though you're down
for the
ring i'm down for that ring yeah see
we're all down
get a ring are
a ring you want to put a ring in there
you don't play boxing the problem is you
get hit and you don't want to do it
anymore
we can finally do he's he's young he's
21 that you punch in the face
i've boxed before i've actually like
sparred before i know how to take a
punch
do you i want to i want to go up against
you i love him people oh
he wants to fight you we can do it if
you want we can do it if you want
when people say that i mean this is just
me you're not
you can't take a punch dude you get hit
in the head it's really bad if you get
hit properly with headgear
music doing how do you think for real
that's good you you can move your body
and stuff but but
like you get you have to go to him and
bert
bert uh co-hosted king of the sting
this week yeah he's one of my top five
favorite people of all time he's a good
man
yeah he's great he's [ __ ] strong you
ever seen
bert hold on you're longer than
everybody else he had what surgery
surgery on his arm for what um
he shot a movie you know they made a
movie the you know story his epic story
the machine
russia yeah i made a straight up feature
film on it did they really
he's crushing it man good for him is he
on variety like that that's
well that's him just before surgery he
got all high was yeah in his shows
while he was high he's like denver
albeit red rocks
he made the doctors play this music in
the background he's amazing
yeah you can't play them i think he's a
good athlete
like i've watched him like i think it
was golf and stuff he does he won
variety like comic of the decade or some
[ __ ]
wow yeah he's great man i [ __ ] love a
picture of him
he did like a marathon too right like he
didn't really train that hard we
actually finished it yeah he did the
crazy marathon demon train wow
he's doing the new york marathon too
insane
yeah he's a beast man great all right
jim what do you got just because
my thick ass is back on that stationary
bike man and i'm only
using one bike one bike only you can
find my profile on peloton
thick thick boy prez that's my name on
there if you want to follow your boy and
keep up with me
on the bike we're talking about peloton
man and some things are just better at
home
some things are better from the comfort
of your crib i do it on my garage like
psychopath
i'm talking about peloton that deliver
workouts that you guys are gonna love
they can do
from your home all right with pelton
you'll have the workout experience of
your life without even leaving the crib
all right uh they got everything man my
favorite they had curated music i can
i can work out the country hip-hop they
have the exact music that i love the
trainers are phenomenal robin's my
favorite
ally's fantastic they're all great you
can mix in
i do either 20-minute hit works out they
got 30-minute hit workouts
they got 45-minute long cruises whatever
you're looking for we got you covered
man you can choose from cardio strength
yoga pilates outdoor runs meditation
they offer everything
but i keep my thick ass on that bike man
with pelton bike there's nothing like
working out from the crib
learn more at 1peloton.com new members
can try pelton classes
for free for 30 days at onepelton.com
app terms apply that's onepelton.com
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
we got some current events here all
right switchboard
you look like a [ __ ] dj up there i
know there's way more buttons so i'm
kind of still navigating but i'll get
used to it is it cool
it's cool because we we can have if we
wanted we could have up to eight
different camera angles
which would be too many but it's good to
have that option yeah
and devices as well a lot of cameras
when we started we had one camera
i know um so why that lens is wide
what's up this lens wire yeah that's our
that's our best lens too that's the most
expensive one
all right um and we have another camera
coming in and two more lenses
anyways uh you mentioned yellowstone and
my favorite person
like my hero is tim mcgraw like he's
like the number one person i would ever
want to meet he shredded he's gonna be
doing a
yellowstone prequel oh [ __ ] he's and
he's a really good at
like super good actor he's shredded i
guess we got regiments nuts
like when he's on tour he's like doing
crazy workouts
a lot of you probably have heard by that
god damn it
i haven't heard you know instagram has
been down for like uh
a few minutes now why does that happen
instagram there's just too many users
probably
probably have heard by now that we're on
to a new project
and um we're pretty excited about it
faith and i get to
start alongside sam elliott i mean
goodness gracious
uh for the new yellowstone prequel
called 1883.
can't [ __ ] wait it's going to be a
fantastic family saga about the original
duttons and
their journey to montana and how they
founded the the
ranch up there and um written by taylor
sheridan of course
so you know he doesn't miss great stuff
he's just one of
the most special writers i've ever had
the pleasure of reading material from
and
he's a great writer we couldn't be more
excited now a lot of you asked about my
beard so now you know why
that's cool that's kevin costner right
there nothing looks good on you i mean
that's not him but yeah
right you're kidding right i don't know
tim mcgraw country no no no no no i'm
saying kevin
lisner modern west oh this guy yeah is
80.
so he's definitely not running oh it
might be him it's a verified account
yeah it's it's no it's his it's his
account but
he's supposed that stupid picture at the
beach
how old is he now
[Music]
it might be him no that's not him he's
not you think dude
i think my dad on instagram he's not
running that [ __ ]
oh wait we can't play the scene i need
to see this
we can't play that i've i've never seen
the trailer you want to play it and then
just we'll just edit that
out you like this show so for me tv
shows game of thrones 1a
yellowstone 1b what oh yeah excuse me
excuse me game of thrones you're giving
you're giving yellowstone
number two i'm going to give you a
second for a second i'll give it one b
number two i'm going to give you another
you're telling me that yellowstone out
of all the tv shows is your
show breaking bad you don't you've never
seen it
sopranos i watched sopranos silver wow
unbelievable all right um i mean give me
some
any up dexter definitely better dexter
dexter later season so give me some
other tv shows i'm blanking right now
um billions shut up i mean
i don't watch it it's just like the
first thing that came to mind what great
shows are there
i don't like true blood why are true
true blood's good
the yellowstone destroys drew blind the
wire you want to go with the wire
yeah wire no it's been wired ted last
was a good show it's a comedy everyone
keeps on keeping i got to watch
it i you're whatever
but i can't believe you don't watch
yellowstone
uh you guys are assignments [ __ ]
cowboys
it's [ __ ] it's so good and then and then
and then ryan bingham is in it
who's an actual musician ridiculous
on the guitar he's an actual character
on it and he sings
he does all the soundtrack for it i'm
gonna watch it i remember we planned me
my girlfriend planned a day to watch it
and then something happened and i just
forgot about it and what else you but
yeah i'm all over it i'll watch it how
many episodes so far
three seasons uh third season for the
this is the trailer for the let me see
the trailer hey
i need i need before we go any further i
need a little bit of an apology
for what you're here tyros i refuse to
acknowledge your hair what forget my
hair that's a disaster yeah
um tires 450 i don't think so you tr you
asked your trainer
you dude did you touch your trainer no
you touched your nose
just there yesterday how did you confirm
it i said how much that way he goes
that's 450. i bought it
you're paying him it's a tractor and he
said when you when you deadlift it it's
like deadlifting 225 which apparently is
a cinch for me apparently it's a cinch
well it's sent for myself yeah but i'm
flipping a 450 pound tire dude you know
what we can solve this
post a video view dead lifting 425
pounds no i i can't do that no but you
just said you could lift four twenty
five i said i can flip now deadlifts
deadlifts only to here that tire you're
pushing no but the tire
actually you're only lifting 225 yeah
you're not taking all the 425 yeah so
it's not
so he goes he goes he goes you're you're
dead lifting
you're dead lifting 225 you're not dead
lifting for 15 minutes i was like all
right well
that makes sense it probably is and i
don't know if it's who knows what the
you know i don't even know if it's half
that it sounds like it'd be half the
thumb
but either deadlift 425 post a video
then
post a video like i sent you of me dead
living 575 pounds
super easy and that's on a straight bar
yeah it's real [ __ ] what do you do on a
hex bar
buying more i feel like you can do a lot
more for sure because i watched you do
550 10 times yeah with the [ __ ] texas
hex is easier though
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah man 475 seems
like
it's it's getting to be a 575. i mean
575.
it seems like it's a bit of a piece of
cake i did 600.
well i think you'll work up where you're
being you're doing 600 like that i think
you're going to be able to be doing 600
like
that way you did 575. it's only 25. it
will be 650 by the end of the year you
think so
i think so i get nervous about that
though is it worth it is it worth it i
know what i'm
for what for what in case someone breaks
in the green room i have to smash a door
that's for a while
otherwise though i just feel like you're
you're
just [ __ ] with yourself and you're
getting older and that's when one thing
goes
like that and then for the rest of your
life you got that thing true
[ __ ] that this sounds like a guy who
can't dead the 575 though what's that
this sounds like it comes from a guy
that can't no no i'm just it comes from
an old guy who's got
who's got very good movement and no no a
guy an old guy who has no
no pain true right and and my body
doesn't get in the way so i want you to
be doing that small though uh
the sizzle real quick it just shows that
25 of the weight from the tire is what
you're actually lifting oh so
25 percent so hey chin man i mean
but you're right it's it's not heavy it
doesn't feel like you're 20
on the ground 425 i can't do math so
i can't i can't i can't so 10 percent of
four okay
it's 45 pounds okay so it's going to be
80 it'd be 90 pounds 90 something 90
plus 99
yeah so it's almost it's 110 pounds or
something like that so
wait what the tires 450 yeah 20
of that would be 20 25 20. well 20
20 to be 90 90 pounds and then you take
then you take five percent of that
so yeah so that would be yeah it's
almost a hundred it's around 100
pounds 45. so it sounds about right so
you're flipping one pounds congrats
yeah 106.25 yeah wow that's depressing
um let me refresh this [ __ ] chin
you don't have to get all [ __ ]
technically
no but let me just help you out here and
so spoiler in three
two one if you gonna ruin it because i
want to haven't watched dick i'm not
ruining it
okay but the way season three ends why
everybody's waiting
is kevin costner the main character gets
shot
so you don't know if he survives beth
who's also one of your favorite
characters
um who's her who's kevin costner's uh
john dutton's daughter
yeah a bomb goes off so you don't know
if she survives
oh so there's a lot of cliffhangers yeah
like is did all the favorite characters
die
okay it's nuts i'm all over it can't
wait
you're never watching he comes back as a
ghost it turns into
how to ruin a show it's the whole season
yeah
i'm a ghost what else you got jen
um one second so
i wonder if sam triple has like theories
on this too so
now there's a total of four officers
that worked the same triple is all about
it yeah i saw him
on social media what would he say like
there's like they're doing a cleaning
out process here well first of all
because they don't want them snitching
that way something like that
i don't right so the idea would be they
saw something and they have there's a
narrative about the
the insurrection so so according to sam
and you'd have to watch conspiracies
only on rockville but only on rockfin
but but um but actually we have old
episodes are on right where
i don't want you [ __ ] wherever you
get your where'd i hear something it
doesn't matter
because they're not old because it's all
it's all conspiracy there's nothing
about doing it
but either way um they believe that this
is a cleanup job
because well why would four four
suicides all by suicide crazy that's
weird and they like with families and a
lot to live for and they all died like
what's going on here someone's taking
them out huh
well you know i don't believe in that
stuff but because you just think it's
coincidence
all four of them come through i am very
very confused well it was four or four
people
if there is or different officers if
there is a conspiracy that's a good
conspiracy i mean that's pretty [ __ ]
coincidental dude
four of them fourth known suicides the
police officers who fought back against
the violent mob
and then one of them died 17-year
veteran so really
five died of suspicious circumstances
because the first guy that died died
of like a stroke and like he was but
they don't know what happened so
five police officers died it's very very
suspicious
suicide it's all suicides four yeah yeah
that's the
smoke there's a little bit of fire a
little bit
what are we doing here didn't only one
person die
from like one one woman was shot two
people died right
there's one just that woman right yeah a
guy jumped up and got shot yeah shot it
shot her in the throat
yeah wow there's something so far 18
police officers can i see this have
let me see it scroll down a little bit
have died by suicide in 2021
that's just overall though well it's
been tough for cops because they're
treated like the toughest and made and
turned and made
into bad guys how does that defund the
police going by the way i was just
wondering
uh how's that why don't you look at the
cities that did it yeah how's it going
in those cities
how is crime in those crushing yeah how
funny that is
and now all the [ __ ] politicians that
were crying defund the police
are like we need more cops i've never
been about to fund the police
i never said that [ __ ] you because
you're recalled bh
next one yep um all right so the baby
god he's [ __ ] so he came out with
those anti uh gay remarks it seems like
homophobic slurs dude
everybody's dropped everybody he can't
work so all the different
uh festivals these festivals are
dropping them and also this song that he
had with dualipa
um they're being pulled from it's a
great song being pulled from a lot of
results
as well i mean that's how they make
money too man please christ like dude he
lost
every i don't think you realize the
backlash she was gonna get
i don't understand that though what do
you mean think about all the rappers
like eminem like all of them back in the
studio
about early 2019 he's been canceled
who people are wondering what it was
going to get to rap
here you go castle culture comes from
now now when he talks about
[ __ ] [ __ ] and shooting people
we're all cool whatever but when he
talked about
trans you know and home homophobic
that's it
because then you're getting out of the
african-american culture then you get
into the people that run the networks
and the radio stations and
all the music festivals they're like
dude you don't be part of this
pink mafia you know i do kind of feel
like
if that's how he feels like then that
that's just how he feels so if
people he's got to pay the consequences
for sure right but if that's how he
truly feels
then like that's just my thing that's
how he feels you're a [ __ ] idiot and
then also
if that's how you feel and you want to
be in the entertainment industry which
a lot of successful gay people run
you're a [ __ ] for saying those comments
100 and then now
you're not going to have a career dude
my thing also is that so keep it to
yourself yeah
if he if he like uh my thing is
there was no need for it but never even
back in the day
i never ever thought it was fun to make
fun of gay people or people who were
different i just didn't i don't
get i don't like that kind of humor so
you were never going to hear me on stage
use the f word even in the 90s i just
didn't like that
i don't like it because i don't want to
hurt people's feelings right that's fine
my thing is that if you are not actually
homophobic
but you are clumsy in your language and
then you get
and then you get [ __ ] destroyed even
though you apologize and they don't care
because there's no redemption that's
where i have a problem with cancer
culture
i'm still not sure on his comments
though like it's not that's what i mean
here
no so what was he saying like all you on
the parking lot second dick
hiv it was insinuating from what i heard
it's it's insinuated that he just did
he's not like down with gay people but
wait so he
apologized twice does that mean anything
and is there any redemption lebron
you're right so
that's if he if he apologized like he
did the second time yeah the first time
he didn't really his apology was kind of
you kind of
yeah that's why yeah that's why people
are getting upset but i think if he
comes out saying that i'm like jesus
christ i [ __ ] up i wasn't aware
yes of what i was saying i didn't mean
to do this
thinking he was like i [ __ ] up i've
educated myself i definitely didn't mean
to hurt all these people
i made a mistake then he should be able
to work
for sure like i think everyone's it's
not like he beat up a trans person or
beat up a gay person like
he said some stupid comments he's
probably under the influence at a rap
concert
oh my god he drinks and smokes so he
made a mistake
he shouldn't lose his livelihood off a
mistake
well off of that you know like what nick
cannon did with the anti-semitic and the
jew stuff
terrible and he's a smart dude he paid
the price right
but then apologize came back learn learn
how he's back
yeah that's how it should work i just
think there should be a road to
redemption
of course you shouldn't get voted off
the island because you made one mistake
do you think the baby would have gotten
canceled if he didn't come out with like
if he didn't say all this and it was in
a song instead do you still think he
would have got
it's canceled though different right
because it's art there's a there's a
it's just him talking off the top yeah
yeah
that's what i'm saying like if they
don't have a problem with it if it's
going to be in a song and then
did he do a song with do alipa yeah and
isn't she
uh gay i'm not sure i think she's bi
yeah that's why she like condemned his
comments and then you know
well it's also now it's very stylish to
say you're bi when you're not bi
and there's all that stuff or you might
be bi but i just feel comfortable saying
it because that's more supportive
yeah i'm very gay gay on man
but also it's like when i like when we
joke around and i go gay
i'm not saying you're what you're the
activity you're doing is homosexual
yeah does that make sense of course all
right talk about
i mean i think it's bros you and i this
is a pretty bro podcast
it's the brilliant i genuinely don't
think we've ever been homophobic
you're not we're not actually homophobic
because we're not yeah friends i have
friends
yeah but also i don't want i don't want
i love tim dillon he's a gay man
yeah but also we know my favorite yeah
i'm not interested in
in that i'm not like i'm a cousin who
was murdered for being gay yeah and what
were we talking about
yes the thing is you guys are also
professional
comedians you're comedians that's pretty
much what you're trying to
laugh that's what you guys do we're also
gay we're also 10 or so
we're also i'd say 30 but maybe 30. it
depends how much tiger thick i've had
yeah
10's not enough i mean i didn't see
brian peeking over the stall when i was
going to the bathroom the other day
that's your initiation in the club just
a little bit more see what you're
working with
uh brian's 30 i'm 10. okay let's go to
halsey so halsey posted a
picture of her nursing her newborn she's
gorgeous oh yeah and also her boobs got
bigger obviously because she's
filled with milk daddy um so this one
i'm actually surprised by this remember
we saw this before
i thought it was picture i thought it
would be taken down because there's a
breast
like a you know exposure but because
i'm not sure she's the one who had she
was always worried about her body and
stuff and hiding her
no not her are you thinking of uh
who's bodied up dude i can say like
she's legal now bodied
up really but she's like super
self-conscious because she's a thicker
girl oh okay
i know the guy dating her yeah but i've
never seen like when women have to hide
breast feeding it drives me
nuts like what's a little weird when
you're in like
chili's and they got their tits out and
you got a full rack of ribs but if
you've got
babies you know what they're like if i
get a milk shake you can follow me baby
but also get your tit on my face though
you know like go in the back
well let me ask you this like like take
their shirts off can women take their
shirts off
a lot of times you get that's right i
don't give a flying [ __ ]
but it'd be a little weird if you this
girl just pulls their tits out in the
middle of tgi fridays you know
i don't mind i don't care yeah i don't
know if we're at a beach and some hot
girl
tits out the problem is the hot ones
don't get them out the warlocks get the
flapjacks out but whenever you go to
another speech
you'll see they got no hot girls like oh
let's go to nude beaches it's always
these warlocks like
i feel like going to the beach yeah warm
cheese with feet everybody's melting
yeah
so i didn't know that she she wants
people to refer her as she or they she
actually stopped doing media because she
did a
interview and they kept referring to her
as she
no she's fine but maybe not her this
this this trans this trans stuff is
really this is where i this where
this is where you check it out i check
out because it's become
so trendy and and and [ __ ]
actors and singers want nothing more
than attention
attention and that's why they're doing
it they all do it like like demi lovato
has
run out of options i mean gay depression
suicidal i'm like bro if you're dealing
with that
we don't need to know what you're under
i don't need an article to rolling stone
every time you change your pronouns
never underestimate what
what what entertainers are willing to do
to stay in the spotlight
and they will hijack and approach my
of girls now in some in some classes say
30 of girls in some classrooms now are
identifying as
trans that's only because it's called
social contagion
you also have places in washington where
a 13 year old a 15 year old can get
puberty blockers and
even a double mastectomy without the
consent of her parents
this is where it's getting [ __ ] crazy
so when you say that kids
are not able to do this you're wrong and
this is where i think
as an adult if you want to make those
choices it's fine but when you're 15 and
13 and you have a whole apparatus an
agenda a political ideological agenda
that is
allowing kids to do irreparable
irreparable changes
i told you i want to be robocop at the
third body yeah but my thing is with
halsey it's like all right you change
your pronouns tell your
you're not doing interviews anymore tell
your family and friends we're good we
don't need to be
like dude like i know you want the media
attention you take a picture
breastfeeding your kid which
all set up everybody bear brushes
because their daughter is trans yeah i
don't buy it i don't buy it
but also i don't need an article on it
like why do you need exposure on this
right just do just
dude demi lovato and i love i think
she's so [ __ ] talented i think she's
smoking a mess
yeah i'll sign up for that i will i will
be your companion
through this world but the thing is is i
don't need to be your guy
let me be your guide to this rough world
do you know heartless oh my god
will be trans or to be gender fluid oh
my god give him better further down
um yeah just with demi lovato i don't
need another article
that you know you dyed your [ __ ] dog
pink it's amazing
it's a it's [ __ ] amazing how much
attention do you need
it all the attention no they're just to
the point where they have to be
they're media [ __ ] it's just like dude
i'm telling you i looked at my ticket
sales in north carolina
april 19th 21st it's low i'm going yay
just for that weekend yeah just this
weekend brendan schwab
brandon shop five shows nine and he'll
be [ __ ] guys
as well if you're one of those honey
holes can get pounded come work out with
him and then pound his honey hole down
this honey hole that's right
guys because he's big guy that's when
you know business isn't well when i turn
gay that's right
what else you got but yeah you know i've
been
since doing this job like all the
different articles you just start
noticing patterns but you know certain
slides yeah pop up you realize
after a while like it's so obvious it's
so i don't know how people don't
really like get hip to it it's like you
don't think every two months when demi
lovato
does something random as [ __ ] you
there's she's so frustrated her pr
team's paying for
all that doesn't she know that she's
paying millions of dollars for you to
know that her pronouns changed this
month from last year
don't they know this like i've always
felt that way i don't believe
it but they're putting it away but also
make music
yeah and also just do your thing you
don't make a big old but like with
halsey it's like right you said you're
not doing an interview
that's fine so we don't what are you
doing then yeah just tell your family
and friends your pronouns we're set as
somebody who's been
an actor i'll call you heard him he i
don't give away somebody's been an actor
for 25 26 years and
shut up i've watched people become
famous and watched who becomes famous
and also just watch this
business and watch like as i get older
like i am never
it never ceases to amaze me the the
whole
that that people cannot feel like some
people yeah they're such a mess
and i just lose my respect at the end of
the day for a lot of
celebrities they just are such stuffed
how about john cena jesus christ dude
the whole thing is embarrassing and
there's so much pressure though
because it's like dude china's your
biggest market well
yeah and for me i'd be like i got enough
money i'm not selling myself i'd be like
dude i'm good i i don't want to do this
man
i'm going to get destroyed in america
yeah and then vince mcmahon goes
shut it show me your tits well you're a
[ __ ] at the end of the day if you want
to use yours
he seems like a cool guy i don't know
seems all right he seems like a cool guy
i don't like listening on all the
steroids i don't give a [ __ ] that's
natural dude
yeah it's natural he is i'll say this
he's got the thickest wrists i've ever
seen in person i've never seen him risk
her hands
i've never seen it in my life big dick
his wrists are and his hands are this
big he's a giant man yeah
there's jean shorts and knee braces
whatever uh what else
let's uh change it up here this is ryan
reynolds for his new movie
free guy i'll just play for i don't know
if i can actually i played on the show
but i just played for it
i love him he's so good he's so funny
i'll tell you i don't have time for that
it's a chain dude that looks like mark
harley
his body he's jacked
that's great cgi that's so funny
and it's cool that he puts his other
movies in the trailer for his next movie
yeah he's a beast yeah he really is you
missed some good whiskey cow
yeah i was pissed get a cup man
oh yeah and you're fighting christian at
the end of the month we're gonna ring
crystal christian i'll beat you up next
though after do i get moved up
i think you want to piece the old man if
you do i'm gonna pitch you he's gonna
[ __ ] you up dude
yeah i really will and and he'll [ __ ]
it can
can we include kicks you want to kick it
up i mean i don't know how to kick so i
need
perfect perfect oh are you gonna train
me i'll throw a [ __ ] wheel kick and
[ __ ] blow his [ __ ] out but are you
going to i'll take on account if you
you might have to train someone to beat
cal no
all right on my own
oh uh christian has the bottom i
honestly don't feel comfortable hitting
dudes i know in the face
yeah i always think it hurts man it
doesn't
yeah you're gonna fight to the death you
know in a couple of the sparring
things i've done do you worry about
trial by battle like game of thrones my
friend i hit my friend pop-pop and i hit
him
because he was coming at me really hard
and i hit him and he went he kind of
fell back got stun
flash knocked out he just went oh my god
he goes oh and he had to stop
and i felt [ __ ] terrible yeah i will
[ __ ]
hurt
[Music]
there's no upside for me in this but i
will [ __ ] suck you in your old face
yeah you would hit too hard the problem
with boxing is if you if you hit me yeah
there's no playback
i get i get a [ __ ] floater in my eye
or i get it it's really a problem
like if you try to spar with him like if
he hit you it'd be really good i would
be scared
that's just so stupid why would he but
you would never you would never just ask
him like i would never start
anybody if i said i want to spar you and
i was really serious he would go i'm not
doing it yeah i need all the brain cells
well no because if you you if you hit me
you'd feel bad because you can really
hurt
like headgear doesn't actually help you
it just says it just really helps with
it actually makes it worse
it helps it just keeps it just cuts
concussion's still there yeah like if he
hit if he jabbed you if he went
pop and jab you you'd be in big trouble
but we'll have fun we'll have to have
this
out we were just talking about fighting
yeah and they're in the break
i i think that the way boxing right you
need to
stop fighting i do the way and i paid
for it but then i didn't wear it
i came back to it it doesn't really work
though i don't it does but you got to be
concerned my girl has it she was every
night
what do you do the kid wasn't consistent
and the problem is you got to keep going
because your teeth go oh
you guys stop now going back to my old
bro again i'm just spitballing ideas
here it could be the
uh the tiger thick whiskey we're going
to wiggy up
here's my thing we're going to wake you
up they even came to us and i got mad at
it this question goes let's do the wig
i'm not going to reach out mad at me
yesterday it was the first time i
saw that i don't know so just hear me
out just let me let daddy do this let's
how do you do this okay
we're going to wake wiggy up getting
they're on board the the company reached
out we're going to wiggy up
and we're going to give you metal braces
metal mouth and we're going to fix your
teeth
metal braces metal blades perfect timing
do it see what happens dude metal br
dude metal braces
metal braces see that metal
hey hey hey hey hey
battle of the black shirts on my
shoulders your shoulders are hurt
no oh dude you can flip 400 pounds yeah
yeah there you go
now i would see this yes see what i do
so just so you know
knees up here okay okay bang i just
caught you
i'm showing you what i can do i'm
showing you get your [ __ ] don't ever
try that [ __ ] with me
get the [ __ ] out hey hey hey big guy
hey i look dude this is my bar get the
[ __ ] out this is how i control people
get the [ __ ] hey keep him keep going
keep your hands down hey big guy big guy
you got to sit down this is my bar
is this your boat yeah it's my bar dude
i'm so sorry all right that's all right
i'm sorry have a seat
sit down no i'm sorry sit down
i can see you guys push me down what why
can't you tell
me i used
dude hey i'm dead serious will you read
this one when my voice gets this way i
get serious no i can see you're getting
no
no don't be i'll just see where your
feet were no no
all right hey hey
hey sit down no i'm sitting down i like
to look in your eye cause you're getting
mischievous
watch the cameras listen watch the last
time we're gonna have that table
watch the camera all right watch get the
[ __ ]
listen listen jackson jackson
no no i don't know
ah
all right
stay on your feet brian
find out right now brianna find out neil
yep there you go bruh there you go
there we go huh oh
she's protecting all the cameras at all
kiss me you gotta kiss something this is
gonna be old school
watch out dude you saw that you saw i
got this
am i the only one that kind of got
turned on by this yes
yes okay that's good we're
that's not right wow now
so a lot of times when i'm here yeah
when i'm here bang
so that's a ground pound okay
yeah that's what happens gonna spanx
yeah all right take it easy it's not
enough
you have so much debris on your door oh
yeah off my black off of my block
oh it is crazy i get nervous in my i get
nervous about my neck
yeah why are you about neck yeah
but i'm good that's good now that was
awesome
okay we're back yeah you can grab he can
kind of hold up oh no yeah that's me at
ten percent look at my [ __ ]
this is how you look muscular when
you're i'm relaxing
relax i'm sorry i had to do that to your
neck
and i held it there a little bit a
little bit
you are so scary though you can break
your neck yeah i don't it's how
jiu-jitsu
you almost shattered my head you know
what happens to me can i just tell you
something what
when you do that stuff to me i get i get
people
that
i swear to god dude i can teach you how
to beat him
that's what they say i love the internet
and i go oh really
what you're competing they're they're at
the ufc gym in redondo
you can teach
that's my bread and butter that's the
basics yeah
that's the basics the guillotines the ba
the only kind of basics i literally have
these conversations
yeah he's a switchblade i'm like he's a
black belt he did it for eight years
like
hours and 14 but yeah yeah 14 years
and strong as [ __ ] yeah i'll [ __ ] you
dude
dude that's so crazy though yeah i'll
[ __ ] your heart you feel that and you go
oh
cause you just go you just twist it's a
hard twist
got this rug that's a new rug too
sometimes you gotta wrestle
i got [ __ ] all over me sometimes we
gotta wrestle sometimes you just gotta
wrestle it up it's rough house [ __ ]
monday dude it's all is this rough house
it's a rough house let's see here on
monday it's rough house [ __ ] monday
is it here on monday monday i got you
i got you a little linted up sorry about
that that's a new [ __ ] rug dude
makes me nervous i get nervous with your
next stuff i would never
think about it i know it gets me a
little nervous i wasn't nervous for you
one little thing oh
so i can't i can't i'm gonna grab my
hand i'm like whoa okay
all right what else you got tin sorry
guys sorry for that break so we had to
sometimes break a little physical sweat
too not just mental around here we like
to break it physically a little physical
a little physical
just to just to check back in just a
little check back just to feel
the room out a little checking so people
can see what i did now now
johnny or colin christian you guys
feeling good about it i pulled guard
pulled guard there
i pulled guard and i i neutralized you a
little bit there
pulled guard and then i had neon belly
so there's some
things where i will wait and then when
you transition i take it back go for the
move
yeah problem is
if i do one little thing for the next 10
days it's i'm here
is your next or no i'm okay but but
we'll see you tomorrow morning daddy at
least you don't have any shows tonight
no shows tonight but i do have shows in
houston
august 19 20 21 huh houston improv
everybody come see me
yeah and then we got buffalo the ninth
and the 11th i love that club buffalo
helium long flight then we got then we
got
connor flying into manhattan how many
were trading denver you taking a train
to buffalo
i'm taking two planes yeah i couldn't
avoid it i gotta take it
there's no direct to buffalo it sucks
and coming back in a cape walk either
it's a long trip down
you're gonna spend about nine hours on
the plane but you can eat so many good
buffalo wings up there
yeah brendan shaw buffalo bills jersey
you can eat some buffalo wings and then
daddy will be
that's right you know denver i always
loved denver i could be there for you
know how crazy the crowd would go if you
walk out in a b
shop buffalo bills jersey we can get you
one
matter of fact you're gonna wear one
here's the thing
buffalo brian's gonna come with a wig
and metal braces
and a b bishop buffalo bills we already
thought did they sell them yeah they did
they use my name and likeness but i
don't push back
yeah because i like the press did they
yeah hey david buffalo bills yeah
oh well we already did a little fight we
already did a little fight fight daddy
learned i'm not afraid to come come back
at you now here's the thing you come
back at me i'm gonna i'm gonna rip the
hair that you have left off your by the
way i had to hold your hair
and i could hear you yeah oh you sound
like ufc one you hold my hair your hair
your hair is a [ __ ] is [ __ ]
because
your hair would be very easy for me to
use against you now i do at home when i
get home when i do i take the hat off i
put in a man bun
yeah i have full man bun right now you
know what i realized too if i thought
you would use my elbows a lot
oh you should you should try that let me
know how it goes for you here we go
catch you up ribbing you up
cut you i'm a ribbon maker as your girl
she needs this man bun
dude i would love it because i could use
that and do a lot of [ __ ] your girl's
beaks wet you tried to get me here and i
went [ __ ] uh your girl's beak sweat
show her this your girl's beak sweat
your girl's beak is wet my girl's not
watching this right now
she's going to your girl's beak is wet
she has honey dripping on her tits
honey dripping out of her dish yeah dude
what do you think she has a blow up doll
that i filled with honey that's so weird
yeah how'd you know her honey hole is
popping
don't say hi when i get this [ __ ]
hair like this is doing that with your
hair yeah [ __ ] love the man bun dude
yeah ask her all right
we'll just get first chin honey dripping
out of here
so girl has honey dripping over tits bro
man that's a bad metaphor no it's not a
little bit of a sweat
rolling for two seconds right but it'll
get you right we're all gonna make you
sweaty
especially when you get after it and
watch when he snaps the head down keep
your head up here
elbows i didn't like that you couldn't
push me down and i wasn't even braced
that bothers me how weak you are i'm not
weak
we should do a little strength test i
wonder how strong i am compared to me
how many pull-ups could i do right now
not more than me
you're also 50 though dude hold on i i i
can how many how many hanging my bubba
is at the record at cu
you want to put a little money on it
sure right now at 54. sure
i'll just i'll destroy you do we have a
pull-up bar we can bring one in no we
don't have one here i have one
pick literally anything else your legs
might be pound-for-pound stronger maybe
not pull up how many do you do i i set
to work at see you at 47.
you did 47 without stopping 37. you and
i had a contest 244 pounds
two kipping ones you did 31. but not
kipping i don't care
but but i mean i'll be how many can you
do right now i i think i could do
25. i just done this morning how many
did you do 30.
you did 30 without stopping and i do it
every week strict every week
strict yeah we have a bar so you can't
use your legs
it's a bad idea 30 is good yeah three's
not bad
i'm 260 pounds i did 40 as the most ever
did but kipping
they don't count those kipping's pretty
good but no they don't count them
they don't see all the way down all the
way up all the way down
no legs no legs can't use legs you have
to put a bar so if you're
if you try to use your knees it knocks
the bar down oh oh that's
good it's good you did 30 likes that's
what we did at cu you did 30 likes yeah
we put the bar there
it's not that that that i can't do all
right what do you got jen
getting older all righty this is another
one from kat
she says both qatar and italy's men's
high jumpers tied for gold medal
and instead of doing a jump they both
agreed to share the gold for the
well for the first time since 1912. now
stupid i got a problem with that
they said it's like a feel good moment
so how would they have decided to just
do another jump whoever went yeah
whoever wins that will win this yeah you
get the olympics you've worked all your
life now you're sharing with this
dumbass you're not going to talk to
again
yeah no you want to watch their feel
good moment though yeah i do i guess
not really i hate this i i do too but
let's just watch it's gonna get us
kicked off the internet i don't know
no volumes i don't know dude and also
that's a long hug man let's take it easy
we're also so sick
go eat a [ __ ] six inch sub damn that
guy's skinny
he said we can continue with the jump
off then can we have two golds
if it's possible if you decide so let's
see what they say here
dude get off i'll say they both get gold
yeah i guess i thought they would have
had to share that
oh that's metals you both get golds yeah
i'd be like wait i get a gold yeah [ __ ]
it now
see i thought they had to share it like
no we don't do too two they don't care
about wait a minute they're both
there's no winner though yeah you got to
be the best you still got to beat
somebody don't you
yeah i mean that doesn't make any sense
to me dude
if people want to watch this just go get
yourself too dramatic he annoys me
he's italian dude they're dramatic hey
bro
hey no one gives a flying two gold
medals i don't give a [ __ ] guys from
qatar won it look at him the fans are
like yeah whatever dude all right i
can't watch this it's too annoying
you should definitely have a jump off
dude this and here's the thing if you're
guaranteed gold i'd be like
okay and you have two all right that is
celebrities who are suddenly non-binary
those are the two things that drive me i
mean
they both did where they were dead even
right so they got the same points so
i don't know but also i think as a
competitor you have a jump off yeah if
you're a competitor
jump off jump off that makes it even
more interesting you guys are all best
friends
we need ratings oh so you're never going
to talk like from qatar ever correct
correct although they see each other a
lot i think because they compete all the
time
against each other but still get out of
here you have long weird alien fingers
too
they're all they're both lenky they're
super lenky give us one more button okay
so we can't
show this uh video so just google it
yourselves you'll see it
um this one louis ck
is back on tour for 30 different cities
i think yeah
look at the dumb ass at the bottom right
um but then uh also
they got uh that was john cena his first
stop is madison square garden
this is his tour here uh that's big and
he's gonna
i'm sure sell out everyone just like he
said
i mean [ __ ] you know the hamburger
probably the
1a1b yeah yeah i'm giving it to him
dave chappelle is a little too preachy
for me these days but i think uh
look at this i got i got ck and uh look
at this yeah me too
ukraine ukraine budapest he's kind of
cool
ukraine yeah i do have 100 percent he's
one of my favorite [ __ ] favorites
he you know he's done his that's a isn't
that amazing that it's it's a worldwide
thing
stand up now mm-hmm and you don't have
to change your act either really
because they under they listen to the
podcast they they know what's going on
do you think they'll be letting comics
travel by then oh yeah when was this
tour
oh it starts next week the 13th no but
when's the one in europe
oh i'll look back yeah i got offered do
a tour in uh
in europe for the end of the year
already oh amazing i'm not going but
i'm gonna i'm gonna come to europe next
year 2022 february yeah
he'll be fine by then this delta variant
i mean dude london's
crushing it they did nothing figure it
out people
december in boston the vic three shows
at the vic
ohio orpheum theater yeah he's big boy
theaters yeah it's louis ck and they
were writing them off i remember they
were like he'll never be
yeah no i mean dude he paid his he
alright he did his time and he's back
and his thing was weird it wasn't like
it was weird yeah it's just weird five
years it's a long time
to be in jail the longest yeah is that a
chin
that's pretty much it all right kids i'm
being north carolina [ __ ] brian
callin up
august 19th through the 21st north
carolina
uh yeah august 19th 21st i'm in north
carolina then la jolla comedy store
dates change so no more sunday shows
because i have a fight companion that's
sunday
so thursday one show thursday probably
add one so one
probably two shows thursday two shows
friday two shows saturday
that's august 26 6 through the 28th la
jolla economy store
san jose september 9th through 11th san
antonio texas september 24th through
25th get your tickets now
f-a-t-k-z dot com or thickboy.com
there's a fight companion this no
there's not
we did it last week uh here's an improv
once again improv august 19
2021 buffalo new york helium september
9-11 denver colorado
mama i'm coming home no you're not
coming home dude that's my
mommy my mom did ask for tickets i went
nope sold out mom can't go
it's terrible mom can come to my show so
can that numbie they always have front
row seats
they always have fun proceeds
oh man all right what your girl's nubby
girl's beaks wet uh oh your girl's
beak's wet
i do take it easy on the tits
taking the honey out of the tits take it
easy on kid dynamite
uh september 23rd 24th 25th and then
chicago illinois the improv chamber
that's not chicago
it's not downtown chicago it's a
nightmare
it's the suburbs of outside chicago and
then columbus ohio funny bone look at
this
october 8 9 and 10 are you from columbus
here we go columbus why two nights do
you know the funny thing it's so far to
go
saturday it's so weird it's so annoying
right i know maybe yeah so far
okay so yeah [ __ ] sunday can't do
that maybe thursday we'll see
are you thank you for brian and myself t
uh f a tkz.com
love you guys bye